politicians Wanted music warning labels
to thwart the Antichrist in 1981
Christian DJ Michael Mills claimed that
Led Zeppelin Stairway to Heaven contain
hidden backward satanic messages that
could be picked up by the subconscious
that helped convince a California
lawmaker to introduce a bill preventing
recordings that can manipulate our
Behavior without our knowledge or
consent and turn us into Disciples of
the Antichrist the bill mandating labels
on records that contain backwards
messaging passed the California house
but eventually stalled a similar bill in
Arkansas got through both Chambers but
died during the amendment process even a
US Congressman tried to get Federal
legislation passed but it went nowhere
hail sanity yes this really happened